well for several years now billionaire
supervillain vampire george soros has
been quietly pumping many millions of
dollars into lit local district attorney
races all across the country now i
haven't checked his wikipedia but i'm
pretty sure that george soros is about
285 years old at this point old enough
to be joe biden's uncle you know and
he's only has about probably about a
century left to live then
yet he's decided to dedicate these
waning moments of his life to building
an army of rabidly left-wing das who are
all singularly singularly
committed to
not doing the one single thing their job
requires them to do which is prosecute
crimes that's what they're prosecutors
that's what they're supposed to do
thanks to soros we now have d.a kim fox
in chicago who recently refused to
prosecute a group of gang bangers who
shot each other in the middle of the
street also d.a george gascon in los
angeles who's overseen an enormous spike
in crime since taking over a year ago in
that city d.a larry krasner in
philadelphia who has presided over an
historic surge in the homicide rate in
fact a dozen cities in the united states
set new murder records this year largely
thanks to soros das
but we aren't supposed to notice the
soros connection
and if we do notice that we aren't
supposed to talk about it because soros
is jewish and therefore any criticism of
him or related to him or anything he
does is anti-semitic according to the
media
now needless to say this rule is not
applied equally across the board no rule
ever is
because if it was then any criticism of
say ben shapiro or his company the daily
wire or even the beloved children's
authors and his employee would also be
anti-semitic but shapiro doesn't count
for whatever reason perhaps because he
actually practices judaism whereas soros
is a secular atheist but in any case
the latest soros creature to be elected
to the district attorney's office of a
major city is alvin bragg
he's the new d.a of manhattan
and in a memo released to his staff
earlier this week
bragg made it clear that
you know he's been watching all the ways
that his fellow soros goblins have
destroyed their respective cities
and he's concerned that the work is not
being done quickly enough
and that's why brag according to the
memo
will be stepping back from prosecuting
crime
almost all crime including violent crime
now new york is one of the cities that's
experienced a crime surge especially in
violent crime with 485 murders committed
in the city in 2021 that's a jump of
well over 50 percent over the murder
rate just two years ago
but bragg says that those are rookie
numbers we got to pump them up
and here's how he plans to do it as
reported by the new york post listen to
this
in his first memo to staff on monday
alvin bragg said that his office will
not seek a carceral sentence that is a
prison sentence
except with homicides and a handful of
other cases including domestic violence
felonies some sex crimes and public
corruption
quote this rule may be accepted only in
extraordinary circumstances based on a
holistic analysis of the facts criminal
history victims input especially in
cases of violence or trauma and any
other information available the memo
reads
assistant district attorneys must also
now keep in mind the quote impacts of
incarceration including whether it
really does increase public safety
potential future barriers to convicts
include involving housing and employment
and the financial cost of prison and
also the racial disparities over who
gets time brag instructed
well at least they'll still be seeking
prison time
for some sex crimes
only some
you know just the bad ones i guess
so far this all sounds relatively in
line with the brand of lunacy we've
grown accustomed to over the last few
years
but it gets worse from the post it says
bragg's memo also detailed the following
instructions for prosecutors to reduce
charges filed by cops in various cases
armed robbers who use guns or other
deadly weapons to stick up stores and
other businesses will be prosecuted only
for petty larceny a misdemeanor
provided no victims were seriously
injured and there's no quote genuine
risk of physical harm to anyone
armed robbery a class b felony would
typically be punishable by a maximum of
25 years in prison while petty larceny
subjects offenders to up to 364 days in
jail and a 1 000 fine
so you heard that right armed robbery
is a misdemeanor in new york now
no prison time the memo goes on to
explain that of course such trivial
crimes as burglary and drug dealing will
also be effectively ignored
but the inclusion of armed robbery takes
this to a to a new level
the rationale seems to be that armed
robbery does not necessarily create a
quote genuine risk of physical harm
now silly me i would have thought that
there's always a genuine risk of
physical harm
when somebody points a gun at your face
but that's not what a risk of physical
harm looks like apparently you know a
guy who walks to his table at olive
garden without a mask on
now there's someone who's creating a
risk of physical harm
but if he were to merely take out a
firearm pointed in the direction of
somebody's skull and politely request
that the contents of the person's wallet
be emptied into the bag he's holding
well there's no reason to overreact to
that
after all what is it that armed robbers
almost always say at least in the movies
they always say well give me your money
and you won't get hurt do as i say and
you won't get hurt
so really if you if you do become
physically harmed during the course of
an armed robbery it's actually your
fault
you should have just done as you were
told i mean he said do what you're told
and you won't get hurt
i wish that everything that i'm saying
right now was a joke but it's not
here is i think uh one important point
to take away from all this
as much as as the people behind these
policies talk about systemic racism
and the impact of incarceration
and rehabilitation all the rest of it
none of that has anything to do with the
policies themselves
it is not an overabundance of compassion
that drives this
this is not a case of misplaced
sympathies
the bleeding heart liberal stereotype
was never accurate and certainly isn't
today
i'll tell you what actually drives this
actually it's two things
both are cynical and calculated one is
more politically practical than the
other
so the first is simply that this is an
attempt to solve the crime problem on
paper through reclassification
because if you stop treating crime as
crime then the crime goes away it's like
magic
sure there are just as many people
selling drugs and robbing liquor stores
in fact quite a bit more people now
because you're not prosecuting it but
that's only technically a crime problem
if you call it a crime
stop calling it a crime and the crime
goes away
leftist political leaders and da's are
to some extent
sort of adopting the rationalization of
a cuckolded husband who solves the
problem of his wife cheating on him by
deciding that well actually we're in an
open marriage
see it isn't adultery if he approves of
it he thinks
we'll just take this thing and we'll
re-categorize it and
then problem solved
just as crime isn't crime if the people
in charge of prosecuting it are giving
it the thumbs up
that's the practical and the political
motivation
but i think at a deeper level there's
something else going on
this is at bottom
nothing less than an attempt to overturn
human society
to flip the moral order on its head
the anarchy in the streets is all a part
of the plan part of the design
the refusal to prosecute or punish
violent criminals who prey upon the weak
and vulnerable
is a direct affront to civilization
itself
because it flies in the face of every
value we hold dear as human beings
it is anti-human it's anti-civilization
it's anti-moral amoral
there's the real plan
to tear everything down leftism is
inherently destructive it's the only
thing it knows how to
do tear everything down
and then build something new something
hideous from the wreckage
that's the objective
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated